foreign
system has eight planets a few dwarf
planets and more than 200 moons but wait
are you seeing double
or did every planet suddenly get a twin
where would each planet's double fit in
why would Earth 2.0 not support any life
and which planet's twin could turn out
to be habitable
this is what if and here's what would
happen if every planet had a twin
the solar system has three types of
planets Rocky geishas and icy
these all formed after our son was born
from a spinning disc of dust and gas
as temperatures in the solar system Rose
the inner regions were as hot as 1730
degrees Celsius and only substances with
very high melting points like iron
silicon and magnesium could remain solid
this gave way to our Rocky terrestrial
planets Mercury Venus Earth and Mars
further out temperatures were as cool as
minus 225 degrees Celsius
so the outer planets like Jupiter and
Saturn attracted massive amounts of
hydrogen and helium
then beyond that Uranus and Neptune
formed out of methane and water
all these planets formed in the exact
right location with the perfect
conditions for what they are today
especially Earth
but on what if since everything is
possible not only will we double every
planet in the solar system but we're
also going to line these planetary twins
up in reverse order
what could go wrong
I know I know Pluto isn't a planet
anymore it was demoted to a dwarf planet
back in 2006 but for the sake of this
scenario Pluto will make a comeback only
this time instead of being formed on the
outskirts of the solar system it would
orbit dangerously close to the Sun
the original Pluto is about two-thirds
the size of our moon but Pluto's twin
would be much smaller
being so close to the Sun its mantle of
water ice would boil away leaving behind
only a small rocky core
next up you'd find mercury in its usual
first position from the Sun but except
this time on the exact opposite side of
its orbital path it would be joined by
the twin version of the ice giant
Neptune
now looking at Neptune's twin you you'd
barely recognize it the sun would rip
gases out of its atmosphere and pull
them toward the star itself yeah looks
like putting an ice giant right next to
the sun is a very bad idea
what were you thinking
eventually Neptune could be in danger of
losing its entire atmosphere
now you certainly wouldn't see this
happen overnight maybe if you set up the
world's most epic time lapse you could
see this unfold over the next 10 million
years
Venus is often referred to as the planet
of Love which would now be extra
exciting because you could watch it
Circle the sun with a new dance partner
Uranus is Twin
this partnership would be a relatively
harmonious one for both of them and
neither would see much of a change but I
need to warn you Earth's planetary
neighborhood could get stinky all thanks
to Uranus's atmosphere that carries the
whiff of farts anywhere it goes
now Uranus's twin would be a great place
for a quick visit especially if you were
looking to get rich you might get caught
in one of its Diamond rainstorms and
collect some bling that's been formed in
the atmosphere's immensely High
pressured environment
just don't forget your space suit
next up the Earth's orbit
you'd get to look into the night sky
from wherever you are and see the
spectacle that is the twin of Saturn
and you'd be in for a treat a
magnificent view of the planet's
swirling yellow storm clouds
not to mention at least 62 moons shining
down on you
but just because it would be joining us
in the habitable zone doesn't mean this
gas giant would be able to support life
Saturn's twin still wouldn't have a
solid surface and super fast winds would
whip around the planet's upper
atmosphere at speeds of up to 1800
kilometers per hour
the problem is that while you're
enjoying the spectacle this Twin's
gravity would start tearing our planet
apart and its moons might be set on a
collision course with us
odds are that this planetary
configuration would wipe out all life on
Earth
okay okay enough of the bad stuff let's
talk about Mars
the red planet would be paired with the
world that is home to the infamous great
red spot
yeah you guessed it the twin of Jupiter
is about to crash this party
the copy of the largest planet in the
solar system would be located at the
very edge of the Sun's habitable zone
now that wouldn't mean that Jupiter's
twin could support life
it would still be made of gas with no
solid surface but its presence so close
to Mars could cause Mars to turn into a
lush habitable world
Mars is a dry desert with no liquid
water and hardly any atmosphere well
that's largely thanks to The
Disappearance of its magnetic field
which used to hold its atmosphere
together
this likely happened when Mars got
bombarded by asteroids in its early days
but if Jupiter's twin and its strong
gravitational force were around back
then well it could have saved Mars from
those asteroid collisions then Mars
could have kept its atmosphere and maybe
there'd be life there today
or maybe this twin of the largest planet
in the solar system would have sent even
more asteroids toward Mars maybe even
right toward Earth meaning life probably
wouldn't even have the chance to form
okay on the opposite side of our Solar
System's asteroid belt you'd find all
these pairings repeated
starting with the original Jupiter and
the twin of Mars things would stay
pretty much the same Jupiter would still
be big and gacious well Mars would be
cold dry and lifeless
yeah
and then there would be Earth 2.0
now sharing an orbit with Saturn you'd
find Earth's twin way outside the Sun's
habitable zone
here you'd receive one percent as much
sunlight as you get back home
from space Earth 2.0 would look like a
Frozen snowball version of our planet
the oceans would mostly freeze over but
that wouldn't mean that pockets of Life
couldn't still exist under all that ice
deep in the ocean close to hydrothermal
vents there could be enough heat to
sustain life
the tidal motion of the water could move
that geothermal heat around allowing
parts of it to remain liquid
next on the list the twin of Venus
located right next to Uranus and 27
times further away from the Sun than it
is now
this would cause its temperatures to
drop
the original Venus is known for its
scorching hot surface temperatures that
can be as high as
475 degrees Celsius
even this far from the Sun the venusian
twin could still retain some of its
warmth but you wouldn't be able to move
there just yet
it's thick atmosphere would be full of
lethal amounts of carbon dioxide and
sulfuric acid so you'd have to terraform
it first
finally reaching the outer edge of the
solar system you'd find Mercury's twin
circling the sun in the same orbit as
Neptune while the original Mercury is
the second hottest planet this world
would be a frozen Rock
it would also look eerily similar to our
moon
okay that's the end of our journey
through this crowded version of the
solar system but I wonder what things
would look like if it was all a little
closer together
like every planet being within the
habitable zone of the Sun
well that's a story
for another
what if